The EURO is to currencies what TINDER is to Apps: everybody loves to criticise it but…
at the end of the day, a lot of people you
wouldn’t expect end up using it.
I’m sure many of you have heard economists
and experts of all kinds making predictions
about the end of the single European currency.
The best thing Germany could do for Europe
is quit the single currency – but it won’t
Larry Elliott for The Guardian
“The euro is a patently flawed construct,
which its architects knew at the time of its
creation” –George Soros
Nevertheless, the reality is way different.
In fact, the EURO is the second most common
worldwide reserve currency.
And at the end of this video, you’ll see
how it might not be far from being the first.
Think I’m going nuts?
Definitely not!
Look, one third of the International trade
uses the EURO as its exchange currency.
20% of the reserve currencies from central
banks are denominated in Euros.
And many other countries also issue debt in
this currency.
But this is not the end of the story!
If you follow VisualPolitik every week, you
already know that Donald Trump is putting
lots of tariffs on international trade…
So what does this mean?
Think about it!
If Americans are going to buy less stuff abroad,
there will be fewer dollars in circulation.
Then again…
Who’s signing free trade deals with every
mother’s son?
Exactly!
The European Union!
They have already passed a treaty with Canada,
the so called CETA.
But this is not the only one!
In the last two years, Europe has reduced
tariffs with Japan, Mexico and many other
countries.
In other words, the more Europeans buy abroad,
the more EUROS there will be in circulation.
This means there could be a moment where instead
of having ONE hegemonic reserve currency…
we might have TWO: the US Dollar and the Euro.
OK, OK, I know what you’re thinking now…
and what good does this do?
Is it really useful for Europeans to have
the EURO as the hegemonic currency?
Well… yes and, at the same time… no.
If you’re watching this video from any EU
country and, let’s say, you have a company,
having the EURO as the World’s reserve currency
won’t help you all that much.
But… if you’re working for a European
Government…
Boy, you are really feeling lucky!!!
If there’s a big demand for euros, the European
Central Bank will have a bigger margin to
print money without devaluing it.
Anyway, we talk about this in our video about
the dollar.
If you haven’t seen it yet, there’s a
link in the description.
Now the big question is…
Why is the Euro more popular than any other
currency?
For example… why the Euro and not the Chinese
Yuan?
Why are so many economists so critical of
the euro?
Today, we are going to answer these questions,
but before we do, let’s take a look back
at history.
EXISTENTIAL CRISIS
During the 70s, European countries were happy
to trade with each other.
Although there was no European Union back
then, there was something very similar, the
so-called COMMON MARKET.
Nonetheless, there was a problem.
Each country had its own national currency.
And each currency worked in a different way.
For example, the German Mark was strong and
stable.
But the Italian lira was devaluing every other
day.
So imagine this situation.
You work for a German bank and you lend 1
million liras to an Italian company.
In this moment, a million liras are worth
1000 German marks.
But when it’s time for that Italian company
to give you back the money, the Lira has been
devalued.
So, even if you get 1 million liras back,
when you exchange it to your local currency,
you only get, say, 900 german marks.
A hell of a business transaction!
Isn’t it?
OK, so in order to avoid this, the European
politicians met in a room and… well…
…apparently they tried something… pretty
strong.
They came to an agreement called the... snake...
in the... tunnel.
So, well, the snake is kind of a methaphor
for the currency fluctuations... right?
Because... you know, currencies go up and
down like a snake.
So, if you don’t want the snake to go crazy...
you...
make a tunnel, right?
This way... the currency doesn’t fluctuate.
Well... look my dear viewers: this was the
70s, a crazy time were Bob Marley was still
alive and bellbottoms were trendy.
So did this snake in the tunnel agreement
work?
Of course not!
During the 80s, European currencies went up
and down like a... drunk snake in a very wide
tunnel.
This is why, decades later, European politicians
met again in another room.
This time it was 1992 and this agreement had
a more proper name: They called it the MAASTRICH
treaty.
And in this one, they got really serious and
said:
Let’s not fuck around!
We will create a common currency for all.
No more exchange rates, fluctuations, or bullshit...
What?
What do you say, Great Britain?
You don’t want in?
OK!
Great Britain!
You can go fuck yourself with your sterling
pound, your five o’clock tea, and your driving
on the wrong side of the road!!!‘
And this is how a three step process to create
a single currency started.
In 1999, all the EU stock markets started
listing in Euros and, later on, European citizens
started using the new coins for their daily
trades.
Now we all have gotten used to hearing about
Euros like any other normal currency.
But make no mistake, back then, it was an
unprecedented financial experiment.
And... this is how the first critics came
up.
Europe exemplifies a situation unfavourable
to a common currency.
It is composed of separate nations, speaking
different languages, with different customs,
and having citizens feeling far greater loyalty
and attachment to their own country than to
a common market or to the idea of Europe.
–Milton Friedman
And now you might wonder…
What is the problem with a single currency?
That’s easy.
If we have a single currency, that German
bank we talked about before, will have no
problems lending money to an Italian or a
Greek company.
So what happens, then?
Well… since there is no currency risk, German
banks, having a lot of money, lend it to poorer
Italian, Greek and Spanish companies.
All of a sudden, rich countries started investing
in poor countries like there was no tomorrow.
And yes, yes, I know what you’re thinking
now…
Where’s the problem, then?
Well, the problem comes with the crisis.
Banks must take bigger losses on Greek loans,
says German finance minister
Basically, the Southern European economies
are poorer and weaker.
When there’s a crisis, their companies are
the first ones to go bankrupt.
So if companies can’t pay their debts back,
the banks can go bankrupt too.
This is what we call the RISK OF CONTAGION.
This explains why, during the 2008 crisis,
so many politicians and economists suggested
abandoning the Euro.
Many of them talked about the creation of
two different EUROS: one for the wealthy countries,
solid and stable, and another for the poor
ones.
One that could be severely devalued.
Nonetheless… today, the EURO is still alive
and kicking.
Why?
We’ll see right now.
LONG LIVE CHAOS!!!
Critics are right: the European Central Bank,
also known as the ECB, is a modern day Babel
Tower.
It works similarly to a country’s government.
The current president is a man named Mario
Dragui and the executive board is something
like the executive power.
But we also have a legislative power: the
Governing Council.
This is where you have representatives from
all the Eurozone countries.
There’s one from Spain, one from France,
Germany, Slovenia… well, all the countries
that have the euro as their currency.
These guys are the real decision makers.
They decide whether to raise of lower interest
rates or print more or less money.
But before they do, they have to reach an
agreement.
And this is where the problems start!
The Southern European countries want to print
more money but their Northern neighbours don’t.
Since they can’t come to an agreement, it’s
almost impossible to make drastic decisions.
This is all true and the problem is…
(((LOOK AT THE CAMERA FOR 4 SECONDS IN PURE
SILENCE)))
… ahm… well…
Where is the problem?
I mean, where is the problem in having a currency
that cannot be devalued because those who
are in charge of printing it don’t agree
with each other?
Isn’t this a strength?
We talked about this thousands of times on
VisualPolitik.
The best currency is the strongest one.
If the value of your money doesn’t change,
there is low inflation and you can do your
shopping without being afraid of losing your
money.
You can start your tech company because you
know you can invest long term.
And you might wonder now… but is the EURO
that stable?
Well… look at this chart!
Here you can see a comparison between the
monetary supply, the so called M2, of the
ECB and the American Federal Reserve.
Can you see how they go hand in hand?
In less than 20 years, the EURO has become
as solid as the American Dollar.
In fact, Europeans have already forgotten
what inflation even is.
For a better understanding, the American Federal
Reserve has two main goals: keeping inflation
low and keeping unemployment low too.
The European Central Bank, instead, has just
one goal on their agenda: monetary stability.
And, so far, they have achieved it!
So yes, we can say that the EURO is as solid
and abundant as the USD but… could it be
even more solid and abundant?
Well… the answer is yes.
Today, Eurozone has around 320 million inhabitants…
almost the same as the United States.
But despite the European economy being poorer
than the American one, the eurozone can increase
as long as new countries join it.
In the last 10 years, 6 new countries have
adopted the Euro as their currency.
And, despite the political climate not being
very in favour of it, Poland of the Nordic
countries might end up using it at some point.
If this wasn’t enough, there are many other
currencies that are linked to the EURO.
Do you remember this other video where we
talked about the French colonies in Africa?
There we said how countries like IVORY COAST
and SENEGAL have a common currency called
the CFA FRANC.
This currency is linked to the EURO.
And we’re talking about more than 150 million
people in emerging economies.
In other words, with so many people using
EUROS in their daily lives, there are enough
coins out there to make it easy for any company
to get them.
But, OK, now you might be thinking…
Yes, Simon, a lot of people are using Euros
but… you know what other currency has a
lot users?
The Chinese Yuan!
Also known as the RENMINBI.
It’s becoming more and more in fashion nowadays…
so…
Why are we gonna use EUROS and not RENMIMBIS?
Well, we’ll see why right now.
YUAN’S FLAWS
You’re right!
China is full of Chinese people!
And those Chinese people use YUANS, also known
as RENMIMBIS, for their daily transactions.
This means high great demand for this currency
and lots of notes and coins in the market.
At first glance, this should be enough for
the YUAN to become an international reserve
currency, right?
Well… there is a problem…
China puts US$15,000 annual personal cap on
overseas bank card withdrawals
Yes, you heard this right: China does not
want yuans to leave the country.
This is why they put lots of capital controls
in place.
In other words, finding yuans in the international
market is not an easy job.
In fact, China wants to avoid Chinese businessmen
taking Money out of the country.
Hence, the Chinese People’s Bank has lots
of restrictions.
And, as you can imagine, in a dictatorship
like the Chinese one, it’s hard to believe
in the independence of their central bank.
In other words, if Xi Jimping needed to, he
could change the Governor’s bank and start
printing money at will.
Don’t believe me?
Do you really think a political system doesn’t
affect a currency?
Oh, come on!
You should watch our video on Turkey.
There you’ll see what happens when you mix
authoritarianism and economic crisis.
Meanwhile, it’s your turn.
Do you think the EURO can become as important
as the dollar?
Or maybe we’ll see a brand new crisis destroying
the European single currency?
Please, leave your answer in the comment section
below.
Also visit the reconsidermedia website, they
are the podcast that provided the vocals in
this episode that were not mine.
And don’t forget that we publish brand new
videos every week so hit that subscribe button
and click on the bell icon so you will always
have a notification when we publish a new
video.
If you liked this episode, give us a like,
share it with your friends and, as always,
I’ll see you next time.